when it comes to a federal War on Drugs
I oppose it I don't think there's
anything wrong with a particular State
saying we want to ban this drug or that
drug however I I don't think it's wise
as a nation to have this bizarre
two-faced halfway point where we say
this drug is illegal or X Y and Z is
illegal but it's not that serious a
crime you're not really going to get
into that much trouble if something is a
crime it should really be a crime and
that does mean we need to think twice
about what laws we have what we're
willing to ban or make illegal but once
something's not legal you really should
get in serious trouble for breaking the
law I agree with that it makes a mockery
of the judicial system or the entire CIS
legal system if you can't enforce or
don't enforce a law in the book so like
schedule one marijuana's schedule one
narcotic in the United States federally
but it's like no we're not going to
pursue it they don't they won't pursue
it